et on va parler de la situation
économique du liban avec charles abou
khaled qui est président de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie canada
allybar bonjour monsieur boukhaled dans
les yeux et je tiens vous transmettre
notre solidarité en ces moments
difficiles tout d'abord j'espère que vos
proches votre femme et est en sécurité
oui grâce à dieu ils sont en sécurité
avec ce drame monsieur abou khaled al
heure de beyrouth c'est le coeur
littéralement du liban qui a été touché
son coeur économique aussi parce que le
port a été complètement soufflé et le
liban faut le dire c'est un pays qui
mise beaucoup sur ses importations
absolument l'économie du liban est basé
beaucoup sur les importations même la
production du liban a besoin de matières
premières qui vient de l'international
même le secteur agricole du liban à
faire a besoin d importation des engrais
pour le secteur agricole donc
effectivement le port était un le coeur
économique du du liban est aussi puisque
le liban est un pays qui est importateur
et importe beaucoup été une source de
revenus importante pour le gouvernement
du liban via les frais douaniers et là
on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur les images pour
n'en a parlé des silos carrément qui
sont tellement après ou quoi au moins 80
% des stocks de blé du pays qui sont
partis en fumée ou qui sont contaminés
une véritable catastrophe
cc c'est vraiment extrêmement
préoccupants comme situation parce que
on avait déjà une situation importantes
liées à la pénurie du blé du pain au
liban reliés à la crise économique avant
de cette explosion la même le
gouvernement du liban avait subventionné
l'achat de blé et maintenant se trouve
avec les stocks perdu les informations
quant à nous disent qu'on a dû assez de
blé pour un mois donc comprendre est que
pour nous comme chambre de commerce
c'est extrêmement important pour aider
la population de s'assurer de trouver
manière de réapprovisionner à le pays en
blé et nous avons fait certaines
demandes aux représentants
en fédéral à ce sujet donc un risque que
le canada c'est comme grenier le
gratuitement on apprenait absolument oui
et là vous avez vraiment voyez donc une
demande formelle à pablo rodriguez ce
qu'est le lieutenant québécois de justin
trudeau
nous avons de très bonnes relations avec
le bureau de monsieur pablo rodriguez
qui est un grand intérêt la communauté
libanaise ainsi que différentes
personnes fédéral j'ai même eu des
communications avec monsieur champagne
pas assez rapidement donc oui
effectivement on a fait cette suggestion
est parmi d'autres éléments qui serait
très important pour aider le liban
oui et vous attardez donc à une aide
précise la part du canada
écoutez on aimerait en considérant que
le canada est à une belle production de
céréales de voir s'il y avait une
possibilité d'envoyer des produits des
céréales vers le liban justement pour
permettre assez rapidement de pallier à
cette crise plus qu économiques c'est
vraiment une question humanitaire on
sait que le blé le passé c'est la base
même de la nourriture notamment au sein
de la pita s'agit effectivement d'une
consommation est importante également
nos cours au liban ce qui est terrible
pour le pays c'est que le liban connaît
fait sa pire crise économique avant
l'explosion
les réserves la banque du liban
actuellement sont à leur plus beau
écouter effectivement la crise
économique c'est une crise qui est en
train de s'accentuer depuis depuis
plusieurs années et qui s'est accéléré
dans les dernières je vous dirais 5 6
ans avec le fait que des deux plusieurs
demandes de réformes ont été demandés au
liban pour avoir accès à certaines aides
des programmes d' aide internationale
depuis la fin de la guerre du liban dans
les années 90 plusieurs programmes des
dons étaient alloués au liban mais les
derniers donc ça et c'est et ça
s'appelle cède ça s'est passé à marie il
y a quelques années
ben là il y avait vraiment des exigences
très important de réformes tangibles
pour avoir accès à des fonds et les
fonds étaient orientés vers
projet et non pas de l'argent qui est
directement versée en plus avec la crise
dès la guerre en syrie les réfugiés
syriens qui viennent au liban la
présence aussi de réfugiés de palestine
qui sont au liban
ça a mené une pression énorme sur tout
le système économique libanais sur la
capacité de fournir des services et
n'ayant pas accès en plus à ces aides là
parce que les réformes tarder tarder
beaucoup arrivent et basse à accentuer
le déficit et il y avait de moins en
moins il ya de moins en moins de
liquidités au liban qui fait en sorte
que même les dépositaires des gens qui
ont des enfants dans les comptes de
banque au liban ont des difficultés à
avoir accès à ces fonds nous on n'en
parle même pas accès à leurs propres
enfants et la livre libanaise a été
d'évaluer le prix des biens est hors de
contrôle
j'ai regardé ce matin l'inflation est
tout près de 90% à juin alors la viande
les légumes quand elle est pris aux
quadruples est parfois là où et puis
parfois dans certaines dans certaines
sections même plus dépend le
gouvernement essayait de mettre certains
contrôles ou moralement a essayé
d'amener de d'amener certaine aide à
certains produits de nécessité absolue
en contrôlant le prix de du dollar mais
le problème au liban c'est qu'il ya
plusieurs prix du dollar
quand vous avez dit a été dévalué de foi
de 50% de manière officielle mais si on
va au marché noir
la livre libanaise le dollar qui valait
1520 aujourd'hui se retrouvent 6000 7000
8000 dépendamment de du marché et la 50%
actuellement de la population qui vit
sous le seuil de la pauvreté dernière
question est ce que vous croyez que ça
soit du sel pour le pays de se relever
de cette explosion la et de cette
situation économique est terrible
écoutez ça va être très difficile
c'était c'était déjà très difficile il y
avait des discussions entre voix avec la
banque mondiale qui ne laisse qui
n'était pas simple mais il faut vraiment
y ait rien qui est impossible il faut
que les gens décident la classe
politique au liban décide finalement de
prendre des gestes qui sont
significatifs et de mettre les réformes
en place parce que la communauté
internationale envoie tous les signaux
qu'elle est prête à aider donc un moment
donné
ça va être difficile ça va nécessiter
des sacrifices mais je pense que ça va
arriver mais c'est important de
maintenir la pression d'avoir des
réformes et d'avoir de gouvernance et de
la transparence
pour as pour ramener la confiance des
investisseurs
que ce soit des investisseurs libanais
qui vivent à l'étranger comme notre
communauté ici ou que ce soit des
investisseurs qui viennent de l'étranger
pour investir au liban parce qu on
rappelle que le liban a toujours été
qualifiée comme la suisse du prix noria
après demain parce que pas seulement à
cause des montagnes et des plages mais
aussi à cause des opportunités
d'affaires et l'esprit d'entrepreneuriat
qu'on a là bas avec une avec une
population qui est extrêmement éduqués
et qui a beaucoup de capacités pour dans
le monde des services sera de rétablir
natama là la confiance
je souhaite bon courage charles abou
khaled merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous merci beaucoup pour votre intérêt
on apprécie beaucoup
très bonne soirée au revoir